Welcome back everyone it's
Charlie. This is going to be my new video
for the boys season three top 10 predictions
the showrunner just did a big Q&A where he
answered a bunch of questions about what's
going on with season three. The storylines
the new characters like Jensen Ackles coming
on a soldier boy. Even Jeffrey Dean Morgan
coming to season three is a new character.
So we'll break it down. If you're brand-new
to the channel. Be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos obvious he careful for spoilers
for everything that happened during season
two. If you haven't seen any of the episodes
yet, but is starting the beginning number
10. He confirmed that they're gonna do a version
of the Herogasm from the comics. No joke.
The best way I can explain Herogasm in the
context of the show without going so over-the-top
that the video gets to monetize because that's
how crazy gets is it is basically a giant
superhero vacation week that the supers from
all over the world go to like the worst most
of Boettcher's spring break it you could possibly
imagine. This is the clip of him talking about
that. I know it's here talk about their is
gonna be a soldier boy Homelander having
scene, but I will tell you this is an exclusive
for you guys. There will be a Herogasm in
season three. You've earned it. You deserve
it and you're gonna get herogasm season three
the boys he's is a couple different things
during that also involving Jensen Ackles soldier
boy character, but massive superhero pile
doesn't even begin to describe everything
they get up to. So bring your penicillin and
lots of hand sanitizer for season three episodes
imagine that final scene of Homelander from
the end of season two worries on top of the
Chrysler building just doing his business
all over the street way crazier. I can do
whatever I want except is all superheroes
doing it in public at the same time at a vacation
resort together clearly the show is rated
R it's super hardcore. To begin with, but it
should go without saying that the gonna pull
back a little bit from the comic book version
of Herogasm number nine in that same breath
when you talk about that. He also confirmed
that they're not gonna do that Homelander
soldier boy seen as you probably imagine Jensen
Ackles would probably be down for a lot of
things, but he probably would not want to
do that you could totally go read about it
in the comics. If you want to get the full
blast, but remember the really crazy scene
of Homelander with the doppelganger from
season 2 episode 4 there's so many things
we could say about that whole storyline with
the doppelganger in turning into Stillwell
giving him all those glasses of milk with
the soldier boy Homelander seen that the showrunner
is talking at the not doing is closer to what
Homelander almost got up to with the doppelganger
when he turned into another version of Homelander.
The version of soldier boy that shows up during
the Herogasm storyline is also very different
version than the one that Jensen Ackles is
gonna be playing he will be such a beta to
Homelander's alpha chad energy. Number eight
the showrunner said that when Jensen Ackles
shows up a soldier boy. He's going to have
a more contentious relationship with Homelander
when he comes to season three they're changing
a lot about the character from the comics
soldier boy is the boys a version of Captain
America. He was the Americans first attempt
at creating a superhero during World War II
around the same time that the Germans and Vought
were creating Stormfront. Don't worry, I will
talk about her during season three in a second
to but in the comics soldier boy was a bumbling
idiot the got all squad mates killed on a
mission because he was so terrible and the
comic book version of Mallory who also fought
during World War II wound up killing him in
retaliation for that then in the present day
of the comics. There's also someone called
soldier boy to who just wears the mantle and
he just this beta male version of Captain
America who runs the payback team remember
their version of marvels Avengers Stormfront
also in the comics led the payback team. So
there might be some or references to pay back
during season three. The version of the character.
The Jensen Ackles is playing will be more
like Homelander like they say that he was
Homelander before there was a Homelander.
So when he shows up during season three in
the context of the show Homelander will feel
even more insecure about him because he's
such a celebrity what they're doing though
is there sort of giving him a storyline a
little bit like Stormfront. So he'll be both
versions of soldier boy will be the one from
the past and aspects of the one from the present.
So just like Stormfront of the hundred plus
years old, because they were created around
the same time. It also has some history with
Stormfront going back to World War II. Number
seven. Adding to that they said that Jensen
Ackles when he shows up will be one of the
new antagonists he's not the new main villain
or anything Homelander is kind of turning
into the main villain if you didn't already
think he was technically Homelander has not
been the main villain thus far butcher just
thinks about in that way. The way the showrunner
described him is that he said anyone expecting
Jensen Ackles to show up in season three and
be a nice guy is going to be sorely disappointed.
So he'll be a dirt bag just like everyone
else just like Homelander. This is his quote
about it. He says he's one of these guys is
been around for decades of Vought history
and he was Homelander before Homelander. So
he's from a different era, but he's got the
ego and the ambition in it just comes across
in a different way because he's from a different
time, like a less racist version of Stormfront
just as bad but not racist in the way she
was. He's not a Nazi or anything like that.
The showrunner also did say that he's trying
to get Jeffrey Dean Morgan on his new character.
Hopefully he'll play Tek Knight, because he's
a character that they've already talked about
in the world of the show. They talked about
his movies and take that in the comics is
a combination of Ironman and Batman he has
his own Batcave he doesn't have superpowers,
but he uses technology to make himself a superhero
Jeffrey Dean Morgan is also a supernatural
alumni Eric crick he is the former showrunner
of supernatural Jensen Ackles coming from
supernatural you have Bobby Singer from supernatural.
It was a bunch of supernatural Easter eggs
throughout the entire season in the reason
why say Tek Knight is also because Jeffrey
Dean Morgan. If you talk about kind of a version
of Batman from the DC universe. He was Thomas
Wayne inside the DC EU and he was almost a
version of flashpoint Batman in the flash
movie. So just a really cool if they could
bring a modest Tech Data just be a fun week
at that. And if you some of the stuff that
Homelander was up to. This season was messed
up and twisted Tek Knight also has a lot of
that stuff going on to, but number six like
I said Stormfront will be back in burnt toast
Anakin Skywalker Darth Vader fashion the showrunner
was very clear about her not being dead. This
is the clip of him explaining that Stormfront
is not at all dead Homelander said she's being
held in an undisclosed location. We never
saw her die will Stormfront our little Nazi
Stormfront is still alive and for someone
who dreamt of a master race that she's gonna
be like mutilated for a very long time. She
ages slow. So what he saying is that when
she does come back her burns will have healed
because she does have super healing, but shall
be more like older Anakin Skywalker underneath
Darth Vader since armor living out a very
long life is this mutilated ugly looking version
of herself. Number five. They said that Kimiko
will also talk a lot more during season three.
He qualified that statement to because a lot
of people heard him say this and thought that
she'd start giving huge lectures and speaking
out loud know what he meant was is that because
she's been teaching Frenchie to speaker special
version of sign language. She's also starting
to open up more to everyone else inside the
boys to like she had that moment with butcher
where they cannot each other and they both
simultaneously realize what's going on between
Homelander and Stormfront just from watching
them do an interview together she'll just
start doing that with the other members the
boys being more of a team member a more well-adjusted
version of the character, instead of just
being sort of the X-Men version of lady death
strike. She Frenchie seem like they were getting
really close at the end of season to but the
not quite at the relationship level of human
starlight yet but speaking which number four
starlight and Maeve inside the seven with
Homelander. According to the showrunner. They
won't be calling the shots or anything like
that. The not gonna secretly be leading the
seven are making him do what they want him
to do, but even though things are really tense
between them they're going to be operating
business as usual, because Homelander wants
to continue to keep up the slide Vaught needs
the lie of the seven to persist in order for
them to continue making money but as you see
during that ending scene she's wearing her
old uniform again, that should tell you kind
of with the dynamic is she is a little bit
more freedom now within the seven they're
not gonna start chasing her down every time
she doesn't do exactly what they asked her
to do starlight and Hughley are still going
to be a couple they made that pretty clear
in their ending scene when he told her he
was leaving the boys, but she was not so starlight
is also now fully one of the boys she has
butcher's respect and she's totally on board
with their way of doing things. She's actually
way more hardcore than you is but number three.
A lot of you be happy about this black noir's
back story. They did reveal the work in a
learned way more about what's going on with
black noir. Obviously he's a very different
version of the character from the comics made
a couple references to him being more like
a vegetable at the end of season two after
his big fight with Maeve, but that just them
talking about compound be zombies in bringing
people back from the death or from near-death
using massive doses of compound be, but in
addition to teasing that really cool aspect
of the comics will also just learned way more
about what's going on with him as a character
just as we did was some of the other characters
the season like Frenchie getting his back
story number two Victoria Newman in the secret
plot to take advantage of her new post soever
he talked a little bit about this. She's probably
just going to slowly pursue public office
and become a little bit more like Vic the
veep in the comics, who she's based on Victoria
Newman in the comics is a man just called
Vic Newman he's the former CEO of Vought and
he's the current vice president of the United
States who winds up becoming president after
the previous president gets killed. He doesn't
have any superpowers, but he does have deep
ties to Vaught, so obviously the TV show version
of Victoria Newman is very different, but
it seems like she's heading in that direction
like eventually she can use. This post running
the office of superhero affairs regulating
superheroes and Vaught and slowly tried to
run for office in this also goes hand-in-hand
with the future of the show because the showrunner
said that they have five seasons of the show
plan for those either wondering how long is
a going to run. He said five seasons. He also
made a joke saying that I try not to plan
ahead that far because he said the supernatural
was only gonna run for seven seasons. And
look how many supernatural has gone for now.
So I'm assuming they will get to a lot of
the White House running for office stuff till
the later season. So for most of season three,
shall just be running the office of superhero
affairs, but yes I do think that she has deep
ties to Vaught and she is their plant that
they're trying to put in the White House so
that they can control the government. But
number one Homelander and Ryan during season
three. So the big thing with Homelander is
obvious he is slowly losing his grip on reality
that was with that whole psycho scene was
about in that ending when it zooms into his
face and him on top of the Chrysler building.
The one thing that's keeping him from being
a full-blown comic book villain is his desperate
need for attention. He needs the love of people
that's what he backed off when Maeve threatened
him. No one will ever love you again in that
was the one thing that caused him to let up
on butcher and let them go. So they're planning
a five season arc. I think I'll be season
five before we see him finally say screw it.
I don't care what anybody thinks, do literally
whatever I want and he'll go full comic book
villain. It also that goes hand-in-hand with
Ryan's arc them trying to plan a five season
arc out for him will he become the Superboy
or the better version of Homelander that they
want him to be in face-off with Homelander
when he goes full villain they also said that
butcher will be checking in on Ryan from time
to time sort of watching over him, and he's
going to be another version of what Hughley
was for him during season two sort of the
thing that keeps butcher on the good path
being a good person but everyone post all
your predictions for the boys season three
in the comments below for any of the characters
any the storylines I will keep doing season
three videos as they reveal more information.
The be more teasers and stuff is this her
to film early next year. Hopefully they get
episodes out by the end of next year, but
it could be early 2022 before we see episodes.
I will be doing videos for the Mandalorian
season two episodes in a couple weeks when
that starts releasing. So as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should see
all those videos when I post them. And then
after the Mandalorian season to the Avengers
Wandavision episodes will start dropping on
Disney plus as well, but congratulations to
the giveaway winner from my last couple of
big boys videos Sean Clough and the razor hail.
Please email me on the about page my channel
so I can get your contact details everyone
click here for the boys season 3 teaser
trailer and click here for the boys season
2 episode 8 finale video think you so
much for watching everyone stay safe guys
tonight!